hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast development of anti
cancer gene therapies through
understanding of cytokine induced
programmed cell death
presented by Lia Prasad a PhD candidate
at Lehman College in City University of
New York the Graduate Center in city
university of new york i'm susie valdez
and i will be your moderator for this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more about sponsor
our sponsor a thermo Fisher Scientific
visit their website at thermo Fisher com
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on that green Q&A button located
at the lower left of your presentation
window type the questions into the box
that appear on the screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation for
questions not answer today we will
follow up with our participants via
email also please notice that you will
be viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on the icon located on the lower right
of the screen if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
you're having a problem please join me
now in welcoming Lita Prasad leah is
passionate about understanding the
molecular signaling pathways of new
anti-cancer therapeutics
she's a City University of New York
science scholar working in the lab with
dr. Moira sejuani's cancer research lab
at Lehman College in the Bronx New York
she is a PhD candidate from CU NY
Graduate Center Lea has completed her
undergraduate degrees in biology and
forensic science from the University of
New Haven in Connecticut as an
undergraduate she performed research on
highly specific DNA nucleuses for
therapy at Justice League University and
jisun Germany which ignited her interest
in molecular biology research and
therapeutics as a mentor she's able to
share her passion for science research
and encourage undergraduate and high
school students in pursuing their
careers in STEM fields join me now in
introducing and welcoming Lea Prasad
welcome Lea hello everyone thank you
Susie for that introduction and thank
you everyone for signing in today I'm
Lea Prasad a fourth year PhD student
studying molecular cell and
developmental bio at the City University
of New York and the Graduate Center in
New York City as Susie mentioned I work
with dr. Moira suwanee a leading College
one of CUNY senior senior colleges in
the Bronx and this is where I perform
the majority of my cancer biology
research today I'm excited to talk to
you all about how our lab is tackling
cancer by developing anti-cancer
therapeutics for gene therapy so let's
get started okay so as many of us know
cancer is one of the leading causes of
death worldwide right below heart
disease over the years the rate of
deaths due to heart disease has slowly
declined but unfortunately we do not see
any declines for the rate of deaths due
to cancer to come to control cancer
prevention and early screening is key
according to the World Health
Organization 30 to 50 percent of cancers
could be prevented by reducing risk
factors such as alcohol and tobacco
consumption unhealthy diet and getting
vaccinated against cancer-causing agents
such as apv also known as human
papilloma virus or hepatitis B or se
viruses to name a few examples despite
this however cancer can also be a
genetic can also be genetic and even
arise spontaneously and it can go
undetected if proper screening is not
utilized once an individual forms a
malignant tumor consisting of abnormally
fast growing cells treatment is
necessary to extend the life of the
patient to
their quality of life and also to reduce
suffering so currently there are five
around five standard treatment options
for individuals who have various stages
of cancers generally when cancer is
first detected surgery and radiation are
used to physically remove or destroy
cancer cells at a specific location in
the body when cancers have advanced they
evade the body's immune system they
become more aggressive and thus they can
spread spread to other organs thus more
specialized treatments are needed to
attack rapidly proliferating cancer
cells some some of these include hormone
therapy chemotherapy target target
ethera P such as gene therapy and
personalized therapy so gene therapy is
very interesting because of its
personalized approach when developing
any treatment plans for cancer patients
it's very important to look at the
patient's genetic history and the
mutational status of the patient's tumor
not all tumors are alike genetically and
as a cancer advances even tumour cells
can differentiate and become less
sensitive to treatments that were once
effective in said patient because of
this no one treatment fits all cancer
patient depending on the composition of
a patient's tumor different therapies
need to be given to different patients
essentially the goal of gene therapy in
cancer is to introduce functional
genetic material into human cells to be
transcribed and translated in order to
regulate repair or suppress a molecular
mechanism that contributes to cancer
growth by understanding the composition
of a patient's tumor the goal is to only
target cancer cells while leaving normal
healthy cells alone the gene therapy
goes hand-in-hand with personalized
therapy so of all gene therapy of all
gene therapy clinical trials worldwide
over 64% of trials are for cancer
treatment for cancer diseases because of
the ever changing nature of cancer gene
therapy is becoming a more popular
approach so essentially instead of
having a one size fit all or most
approach
the goal is to create tailor-made
therapies for patients who have tumors
with different genetic profiles and just
recently the Food and Drug
Administration announced the approval of
ex vivo chimeric antigen receptor gene
therapy also called
party therapy which will be the first
gene therapy provided to the US market
to treat leukemia the therapy was
developed by Swiss pharmaceutical
company Novartis and basically it's a
form of ex-vivo gene therapy where
patient t-cells are removed and
engineered to express receptors that
will bind to patient cancer cells and
then kill them once they are infused
back into the patient the therapy was
approved to treat pediatric and young
adult patients with leukemia and this is
really exciting news for the
personalized treatment of cancer and we
hope to see additional feat gene
therapies approval in the coming years
so in addition to ex vivo treatments
there are in vivo treatments where genes
are directly put into a patient genes
being developed for cancer therapy
called for a variety of proteins
including tumor suppressors specific
antigens transcription factors cell
cycle regulators receptors and cytokines
our lab specifically studies a special
cytokine called
interleukin 24 as abbreviated il 24
interleukin 24 is a special interest in
gene therapy because it has a selective
killing effect on numerous cancer cell
types while having no effect on
corresponding healthy cells so to give
some background interleukin 24 is a
secreted cytokine and it's a member of
the interleukin 10 cytokine family it
was first discovered in melanoma cells
and initially named MDA 7 which is
melanoma differentiation associated June
7th interleukin 24 normally is normally
produced by immune cells and epithelial
cells and under physiological levels it
has various roles in autoimmunity
psoriasis and wound repair for the past
15 years however in two
has been studied as a anti-cancer
molecule because it specifically target
cancer cells and not normal cells this
is the really interesting thing about
interleukin 24 because when it is
overexpressed in cancer cells it killed
a variety of cancer cells from melanoma
to glioma prostate breast cancer and
including breast cancer stem cells both
overexpression and viral vectors and
administration of recombinant
interleukin 24 protein have been
effective in inducing apoptosis and
multiple cancer cell types including
cancers in transgenic mice studies
interleukin 24 can also cause a
bystander effect in which two untreated
cancer cell adjacent to treated cancer
cells with interleukin 24 will undergo
apoptosis as well this is because it can
induce its own expression of endogenous
interleukin 24 so therefore it does
relate
regulate its own expression the most
important thing about interleukin 24 is
is that it does not kill normal cells
and this has been confirmed in many
studies so because of interleukins
24 specific cancer specific killing
effect it has been studied and Phase one
clinical trials and it is currently in
Phase two clinical trials to determine
efficacy and about and evaluate safety
so as many of you know before a drug can
be put on the market it has to be tested
in a series of clinical trials and be
approved by the FDA before any of this
can happen the drug must be understood
on a cellular level so currently
interleukin 24 is being studied at Phase
two clinical trials however these trials
have been limited to patients with only
melanoma to maximize the effect of
interleukin 20 for two different cancer
cell types the goal of our lab is to
fully understand how interleukin 24
selectively kill cancer cells we want to
know its mechanism of action and what
proteins is interacting with to induce
apoptosis also called cell program death
basically we want to know what molecular
mechanisms are being changed due to
interleukin 24s overexpression the way
we do this is by performing basic
research using cell lines and protein
analysis so in our lives in order to do
this type of preliminary pathway
research we use cancer cell lines as our
model in general cancer cell lines
replicate quickly they are easy to take
care of and they are inexpensive
compared to working with live animals
also there are a lot of data on cell
line because they are used in many labs
across the world so here we have an
imagery market a microscopic image of
one of the most routinely used breast
cancer cell lines called mcf-7 this cell
line originated from a 69 year old
Caucasian woman who had cancer of the
human memory memory memory gland in the
breast these cells could be cultured in
an artificial environment and maintained
for long periods of time usually longer
than primary cells which come from human
or animal tissues but they have a
limited lifespan these mcf-7 cells are
called immortalized cell lines so cell
lines are essential for us to study the
mechanism of action of anti-cancer
therapies including interleukin 24 we
can then plate cells in a variety of
dishes for a variety of assays such as
those that measure cell apoptosis cell
proliferation mitochondrial function or
reactive oxygen species production also
called Ross in our lab we treat our
cancer cells with an adenovirus
that contains the interleukin 24 gene
this same virus has been used in
clinical trials and is multiplicative we
can treat cells with various protein
inhibitors and determine if those
proteins are essential for interleukin
24s killing activity we can also use
cell lines that have proteins that are
mutated to determine if they are needed
for in solution 24 mediated apoptosis we
can also do really cool
immunofluorescent experiments to
determine if interleukin 24 expression
translocate essential proteins to
different parts of the cell
which will give us an indication of
their function in response to
interleukin 24 expression so despite all
of these advantages that cell lines
offer us they do have several
limitations our cancer our cancer
therapy research needs to be progressed
with translational studies first through
preclinical animal studies and then
clinical trials this of course takes
time but it is necessary to learn how
their appease work in a living in vivo
system and many of my fellow research
also they may also know contamination is
also a major issue contamination of cell
lines whether be the introduction of
microbes such as these cells which you
can see here or cross contamination with
other cell lines it can severely delay
our experiment in addition at cell lines
especially cancer cell lines are growing
for too long they can start to
accumulate genetic mutations and exhibit
abnormal morphologies or altered
functions this can affect your lively
reliability of our results despite these
disadvantages we find cell lines
extremely useful for our type of
research which is the understanding of
introducing 24's mechanism of action on
a molecular level it is important to
test your hypothesis in vitro first and
then progress to animal studies to save
time and also effort and also money thus
overall before any drug can be made for
market and must be discovered and tested
in cell lines so back to our protein of
interest interleukin 24 thus far this is
what we know about into skin 24
interleukin 24 inhibits metastasis and
also angiogenesis and it induces
apoptosis and many cancer cell types it
is able to inhibit metastasis by up
regulating and down regulating factors
involved in cell adhesion and migration
it also inhibits angiogenesis by
down-regulating angiogenic factors such
as veg f fgf and TGF these are various
growth factors most importantly
interleukin 24 activates apoptosis
or program cell death by endoplasmic
reticulum stress also called ER stress
interleukins interleukin 10 fourth
effect on ER stress in cancer cell has
been well studied and it is believed
that this is one of the main mechanisms
in which interleukin 10 for induces out
that so in general cancer cells are in a
constant state of ER stress the ER the
ER is extremely important for cancer
cells to thrive because this is the
primary site for protein synthesis which
is essential for the rapid proliferation
of cancer cells and because cancer cells
rely heavily on protein synthesis there
is an accumulation of misfolded protein
of misfolded mutant proteins which
causes a constant state of ER stress
with a higher ratio of survival and two
different proliferation signals to death
signals the cancer cells can adapt to
this condition and survive in terms of
interleukin 24 action we and others have
shown that introduced in Japan for is
potentiating ER stress to such an extent
that cancer cells cannot recover deaf
signals are amplified and the cells thus
undergo apoptosis most it more
specifically interleukin 24 induces a
buildup of Saito solid calcium ceramides
and reactive oxygen species which can
lead to n a popped a pathetic response
our lab has also discovered that
introducing time for interacts with a
ligand mediated receptor called the
Sigma 1 receptor in the ER this
interaction is antagonizes the Sigma 1
receptor and is and it is necessary for
interleukin 10 for to induce it's a
pathetic effect oftentimes in cancer
cells Sigma 1 expression is upregulated
in our experiments 1 Sigma 1 receptor 1
Sigma 1 receptors over expressed by Dino
virus vector interleukin twenty fourth
killing activity is actually decreased
so to further understand how interleukin
24 induces
apoptosis through ER stress we have to
understand what happens in response to
ER stress so in general the cell will
activate three different pathways to
restore cellular homeostasis homeostasis
by increasing folding capacity protein
degradation or by decreasing translation
or protein synthesis so these pathways
include ire1
perc pathway and the ATF six pathway so
as I just mentioned extreme and
prolonged stress conditions of the ER
can contribute to the induction of
apoptosis so we believe that interleukin
turn four is doing this through the
inhibition of protein synthesis by
activating the perk pathway which is
responsible for a translation
attenuation so for the decrease of
protein synthesis we and others have
shown that interleukin 24 does activate
perks to induce apoptosis so one of our
main objectives one of our main projects
was to determine if interleukin 24
specifically blocks protein synthesis
when it is overexpressed and cancer
cells so the reason why this would be
the reason why this would be promising
is because therapeutics that attack
translation are essential to killing
cancer cells because they can disable
the machinery necessary for cancer cells
to grow and proliferate pursuing
translation inhibition can also be a
more targeted and effective approach
that can be used against a variety of
cancer cell types that exploit different
mutated pathways based off of their
genetic profiles so these therapies
could be used again tumors that are
heterogenic in which the subsets of
cells in the same tumor can have varied
morphological genetic or metabolic or
metastatic characteristic and since
interleukin 24 exhibits a broad
anti-cancer effect in many tumor cell
types
it's killing effect could be attributed
to the inhibition of translation as a
downstream pathway of GR stress
more specifically we wanted to look at
translation initiation which is the
first step of protein synthesis to
initiate translation the ternary complex
must be create this complex contains the
math I mean tRNA gtp and the youth and
eukaryotic initiation factors to begin
translation at the start codon so a key
eukaryotic initiation factor is called
AI F 2 alpha phosphorylation of E is 2
also on serine 51 specifically can block
translation initiation which is the rate
limiting step and protein synthesis we
know from previous experiments that
introducing 24 activate BRS and
phosphorylates CIF to elfin lung and
prostate cancer cells so also in
addition interleukin 24 is able to
increase the expression of downstream
markers of the ternary complex so our
goal here was to visit the sentence ibly
determine if the antiproliferative
effects of introducing 24 is mediated by
phosphorylation of E is 2 alpha and
ternary complex depletion in different
cancer cell types so thus we want to
determine if interleukin 24 is an
inhibitor of translation initiation
through this main mechanism so one of
the first things we did was to measure a
is 2 alpha phosphorylation in a variety
of cancer cell types such as melanoma
breast cancer cervical cancer and
squamous cell can swim squamous cell
carcinoma the way we would do this is
first we would grow our cancer cells and
then we would treat ourselves with the
interleukin 24 gene in adenovirus the
cells would uptake the adenovirus within
2 hours and then we could perform assays
on on the cells within 24 to 72 hours
depending on the type of assay we wanted
to do so some of these downstream assays
include Western Bois so Western blot is
for protein analysis to determine if
specific proteins are affected by in
true
20 for expression we can also do cell
viability assays or cell proliferation
assays that measure whether the cells
are living after interleukin 24
treatment we can also do annexin-v
apoptosis assays that measure how many
cells are undergoing apoptosis using
flow cytometry and we can also do
qrt-pcr to determine what genes are
getting expressed in a response to
introdu can 24 treatment so here I'm
going to show you some data here we use
western blot analysis to show that in
all of these cell lines interleukin 24
phosphorylates gif to alpha at serine 15
and below we have our cell proliferation
and a pop Tata gas phase so all of us
all of these cells and different assays
indicated that introduced in 24 was
indeed killing these cancer cells the
same results were seen with the index
and v apoptosis assay so including 24
was indeed inducing apoptosis in these
cancer cells so next we wanted to
directly determine whether a is 2 alpha
was necessary for interleukin 24 is
killing effect so here is me so so here
we use Western blot analysis to show
that interleukin 24 before we show that
interleukin 24 does indeed phosphorylate
if' to alpha next we wanted to employ me
is 2 alpha mutant cells okay so we
treated using so here basically we were
able to get cancer cells from our
collaborator at Harvard and these cancer
cells these cancer cells contained a
mutant form of E is 2 alpha so these
cancers these cancer cells were
genetically engineered so that the ëif 2
alpha this phosphorylation site would be
mutated so instead of the serine f50 at
specific amino acid 51 the Sirian was
mutated to an alanine so in effect what
would occur is that interleukin 24 or
any other time ESA's would not be able
to phosphorylate the specific gif to
alpha so basically what we hypothesized
was that this specific gif to alpha
could not be phosphorylated then we
would not have a decrease in global
protein synthesis so interleukin 24 is
unable to cause the phosphorylation of
the mutiny if2 alpha then translation
initiation would still occur and we
would get protein synthesis and the
cells will continue living so here I
have some data we treated both mutant
cell lines and wild-type cell lines with
increasing concentrations of introducing
24 so as expected the wild-type cells
the wealth of cells showed killing
effects in response to interleukin 24
but as we increase the concentration the
cell died we can also see that in our
apoptosis sa the cells were increased in
their a pathetic effect in response to
increasing concentrations of intruders
new training for when we looked at the
mutant cells that did not have the
phosphorylated form of E is to alpha
there was no significant change in
apoptosis or cell viability so we also
performed a Western blot to show that
with increase in concentrations of in
2024 we see increasing levels of ëif to
alpha phosphorylation in the wild-type
and no phosphorylation with the mutant
cells confirming that our mutant worked
and the inhibition of introducing 24th
killing effect was due to the fact that
E is 2 alpha cannot be phosphorylated so
overall we show that interleukin 24
phosphorylates CIF 2 alpha 2 induce
apoptosis and cancer cells and it does
this by depleting the ternary complex
which cannot
translation and create new proteins for
the cancer cell currently we are working
on another arm of translation initiation
in which interleukin 24 may also
decrease the ëif for complex here which
is required for mrna binding at the five
prime untranslated region for protein
synthesis many oncogenic proteins that
promote tumor growth contain long five
prime untranslated regions so if the ëif
4's complex is not available maybe due
to introducing 24 these mRNAs cannot be
translated to protein which will
decrease cancer cell survival signals
leading to cell death so here we are if
both of these arms are affected by
introducing 24 over expression that will
inhibit translation and thus allow the
cells to undergo apoptosis and cause
cancer sold so in terms of our
continuing and future studies we are
looking at how introduced in 24
expression affects the different pieces
of the ëif 4s complex we want to find
out also how does into loop in 2024
affect mrna stabilization or protein
synthesis so this is one of the
continuing projects that we are we are
currently working on we want to also
verify if interleukin 10 for does
down-regulate oncogenic mrna we are also
looking at additional mediators of
introducing 24 induced apoptosis we
recently found that protein kinase a
also called PKA is a major cell
regulator that plays a role in
regulating interleukin 24 s mediated
extrinsic apoptosis which works through
death receptors rather than internal
signals that tell cells to die we are
exploring the role of PKA in various
different pathways that interleukin 24
normally activates to kill cancer cells
so we're trying to find out if PKA is a
major well about regulator in
interleukin 24 mediated cell death
we also want to know how interleukin 24
mediates its own expression
so what transcription factors are
involved in expression in expressing the
interleukin 24 gene and what proteins
are involved in stabilizing interleukin
24 mRNA also sigma-1 receptor is
involved so as I mentioned earlier
interleukin 24 will bind to sigma-1
receptor to potentiate ER stress in the
cancer cell to cause apoptosis so we are
interested to know if sigma1 has any
additional roles in respect to
introducing 24 expression of mRNA so
overall in basic research through our
studies of the signaling pathways and
respective proteins what we hope to
achieve is to find new targets for
anti-cancer therapeutics if we
understand the proteins that in truth in
24-hour gates to kill cancer cells we
could possibly create drugs from those
binding domains to treat cancer patients
with also by understanding these
pathways we can develop combination
therapies and personalized therapies
with interleukin 24 that will kill
cancer cells in a more effective and
synergistic manner so there have already
actually been studies showing that in
combination with interleukin 20 for
well-known therapies such as Herceptin
and cisplatin they actually work better
with interleukin 24 treatment we also
want to extend the positive results seen
with melanoma patients in clinical and
clinical trials to patients with other
cancer cell types and as we have shown
interleukin 4 targets the protein
translation which is an essential
process to all cancer cells so this
would be a key in developing introducing
24 as a potent anti-cancer therapeutic
against multiple cancer cell types not
only melanoma so overall to conclude i
would like to thank of course dr. morris
awanee
she's an amazing mentor i've been
working with her for the past two years
and she always has really great ideas
and she is inspired
me everyday to be a great scientist I
definitely want to thank my current and
former lab members Wei Lin also known as
Shan Anna hello Mara for Carlos and
Jordan special thanks to our
collaborators dr. actus from Harvard
Medical School and dr. identity and
fellow PhD student Jason who are our lab
neighbors at Lehman College and of
course none of this research could have
been done without funding from NIH and
the National Cancer Institute so thank
you everyone for assigning in today to
listen to my presentation I'm happy to
answer any questions and I welcome you
to connect with me on Twitter or
LinkedIn if you would like to learn more
about what we do at Lehman College thank
you